Traductor: Ciro Gomez
Revisor: Emma Gon
Cuando un equipo de arqueólogos
encontró hace poco
restos humanos de unos
15 000 años de edad,
hicieron un descubrimiento interesante.
Los dientes de los antiguos humanos
estaban plagados de huecos.
Sus caries fueron causadas ​​por
lo mismo que aún hoy nos aflige,
microbios diminutos específicos
que viven en nuestra boca.
Están con nosotros
poco después de nacer.
Por lo general los tomamos como bebés
de la boca de nuestras madres.
Y al aparecer los dientes,
comienzan naturalmente a acumular
comunidades de bacterias.
Dependiendo de lo que comemos,
y, específicamente, de la cantidad
de azúcar que consumimos,
ciertos microbios pueden
crecer en exceso y causar caries.
Las dietas ricas en alimentos azucarados
provocan una explosión de bacterias
llamadas Streptococcus mutans en la boca.
Como los humanos,
estos microorganismos aman el azúcar,
y lo usan como fuente de bloques
de construcción y energía molecular.
A medida que la consumen,
las bacterias generan subproductos
en forma de ácidos,
como el ácido láctico.
Loa Streptococcus mutans
son resistentes a este ácido,
pero, por desgracia, nuestros dientes no.
Aunque cada diente está revestido con
una resistente capa protectora de esmalte,
no es rival para el ácido.
Degrada la armadura con el tiempo,
disolviendo sus minerales de calcio.
Poco a poco, el ácido forma
una vía para las bacterias
en la capa secundaria de los dientes
llamada dentina.
Como los vasos sanguíneos y nervios en los
dientes están encerrados profundamente,
en esta etapa, la expansión
de la caries no duele nada.
Pero si el daño se extiende
más allá de la dentina,
la invasión bacteriana progresa
causando un dolor insoportable
conforme los nervios se exponen.
Sin tratamiento,
todo el diente se puede infectar
y requerir la extirpación
todo ello debido a
las bacterias amantes del azúcar.
Cuanta más azúcar
contiene nuestra comida,
los dientes más se ponen en riesgo.
Esos cavernícolas apenas consumían
golosinas azucaradas,
así que, ¿qué causó sus caries?
En dietas altas en carnes, habría habido
un bajo riesgo de desarrollar caries
porque la carne magra
contiene muy poco de azúcar,
pero eso no es todo lo que nuestros
primeros antepasados ​​humanos comieron.
Los cavernícolas también habrán consumido
hortalizas de raíz, frutos secos y granos,
todos los cuales tienen
hidratos de carbono.
Cuando se exponen
a las enzimas en la saliva,
los carbohidratos se descomponen
en azúcares más simples,
que pueden convertirse en el alimento
para las bacterias voraces de la boca.
Así, aunque los antiguos humanos comieron
menos azúcar en comparación con nosotros,
sus dientes aún
se expusieron a los azúcares.
Sin embargo, eso no significa
que no pudieran tratar sus caries,
Los restos arqueológicos muestran que
hace aproximadamente 14 000 años,
los humanos ya usaban pedernal afilado
para retirar pedazos de dientes podridos.
Los humanos antiguos hasta hicieron
taladros rudimentarios
para suavizar los agujeros
dejados en bruto
y cera de abejas para tapar huecos,
como las calzas de hoy en día.
Hoy contamos con técnicas
y herramientas mucho más sofisticadas,
que es una suerte, porque también tenemos
que lidiar con nuestras más perjudiciales
formas de consumir el azúcar.
Después de la revolución industrial,
la incidencia humana de caries subió
porque de repente
tuvimos avances tecnológicos
que hicieron el azúcar refinado
más barato y accesible.
Hoy, un increíble 92 % de los adultos
estadounidenses han tenido caries.
Algunas personas son más susceptibles
a la caries debido a los genes
que pueden causar debilidades,
como el esmalte suave,
pero para la mayoría, el consumo elevado
de azúcar es el culpable.
Sin embargo, hemos desarrollado
otras formas de minimizar las caries
además de reducir
el consumo de azúcar y almidón.
En la mayoría de las cremas dentales
y muchos suministros de agua,
utilizamos pequeñas cantidades de flúor
que fortalece los dientes y estimula
el crecimiento de cristales de esmalte
que crean defensas
del diente contra el ácido.
Cuando las caries se desarrollan,
utilizamos los empastes dentales
para llenar y cerrar la zona infectada,
prevenir que empeoren.
La mejor manera de evitar una caries
es aún reducir el consumo de azúcar
y practicar una buena higiene bucal
para deshacerse de las bacterias
y sus fuentes de alimento.
Eso incluye cepillado de los dientes,
uso de hilo dental,
y evitar el azúcar,
almidones,
y alimentos pegajosos que se adhieren
a los dientes entre las comidas.
Poco a poco, la población de microbios
amantes del azúcar en la boca se reducirá.
A diferencia de
los cavernícolas de antaño,
hoy tenemos el conocimiento necesario
para evitar una caries calamitosa.
Solo tenemos que usarlo.